friends we have Mass Effect 3 DLC
expanding on the Mass Effect 3 ending
because if you saw my video about the
Mass Effect 3 ending you know I had a
few things to say about it as did a lot
of people a lot of people including
myself did not like it and for good
reason the entire game was great in the
ending left so much to be desired no
closure no choice everything felt cookie
cutter in the same even provoked people
into wanting to believe that the ending
was all a dream it was sad and so
Bioware has given us DLC that expands on
the ending now they said right off the
bat they're like we're not going to
change the ending we have an artistic
vision to uphold and I hated that at
first I was like come on just to give us
new endings but I do see where they're
coming from they're like look we wanted
to tell this story so we're going to
tell that story but it's not as shitty
in our brains as it came across in the
game and I think that was like 90% of
the problem as is every fight any
relationship miscommunication it's like
in the game when the ending was done
everyone was marooned on the planet and
all the mass relays blew up everyone at
Bioware was like well everyone out there
has psychic powers they know where we're
coming from they know what we're
thinking and I think that's very cool if
they think that we have psychic powers
and stuff but we don't wait no we know
well I don't anyway so now they've
elaborated on points in the ending
they've added to the endings and now we
have the Mass Effect 3 DLC ending or
endings I feel like I can stay plural
now and did I get everything I wanted
out of it me it's a world of compromise
I'm not gonna get everything I wanted
out of it you're not gonna get
everything you wanted out of it but it's
a lot better than it was and that's just
as simply as I can put it I mean first
of all in the old ending Joker was just
running from the fight you're like why
is the Normandie running I just didn't
think that would happen in this one you
see why that happens and I still kind of
feel like I'm not quite buying that that
would happen I just feel like they'd
fight shepard on it more but in the end
all right we have a reason now I
probably feel that way because in the
end mission I always take Garris with me
and I just don't think Garris would
leave ever but seriously a lot of points
that I brought up in my video and I'm
pretty sure these are the points that a
lot of people put on blogs in their own
videos they have been touched on in this
DLC and I think that's great I'm glad
that they listened to fans the three
endings that you get be it they're very
similar still you don't get you garrison
Shepard on a beach or the elusive man on
trial or whatever I said I wanted they
have different voiceovers in it that
tell what happens after the events of
Mass Effect 3 you know life goes on
these people are doing this we're all
rebuilding and it shows people doing
that
shows everyone going alright yeah we're
leaving Earth we're not gonna rot here
and die we're helping rebuild you know
it shows the quarians it shows the crow
Gator shows wrecks with this kid and
you're like oh awesome resolution with
the characters that I've grown to love
for years I mean deep down if you really
think about it that was one of the main
things unanimously that people didn't
like about this ending there was no
resolution in the characters and we got
so attached to these characters that's
what we wanted and now that's really
what you get I mean you don't
specifically get garrus went on to be a
cop Joker became a bartender it's not
that character specific but you do see
life goes on within the galaxy and with
the three choices that you have you know
you take control of the Reapers you fuse
synthetics and organics together or you
just wipe out all synthetics the
explanation of the aftermath is very
different and I'm like oh awesome it's
not just three beams of light and then
that then we just assume that it's
different now you get the explanation as
to how it's different oh we're
rebuilding this way oh yeah all
synthetics are wiped out okay that's
very cool I like that and if you
remember I'm a mass effect 3 ending
video I want to say one thing to that
star child how can I ask him the
questions I need to ask him how can I
tell him to go [ __ ] off alright so you
don't really tell him to [ __ ] off or
anything like that and it's not even a
good outcome I'm glad I get to do it I
mean you do it you're like no I'm doing
it my way no I'm not doing it your way
not doing those choices then the reapers
you wipe everyone out and you lose
however if I was a game developer I
would make it to where if you have all
the war assets everything's at a hundred
percent you kicked ass in this game if
you choose to tell the star child mmm I
would make to where you could win with
military might so far the DLCs been out
for like a day and a half or two days so
I don't think people know if you can do
that can you do that that would be
awesome
I'd appoint the DLC I was like I still
hate the fact that they're crashed on
that stupid planet wherever that is with
dinosaurs and poison berries or whatever
they have there and then the Normandy
takes off you're like oh they're not
stuck there that's good to know
in the end you walk away feeling like
the galaxy survived your sacrifice was
well worth it you United the galaxy and
yes they are working together you fought
so your crew could live and they live
everyone got away from Earth life goes
on even without the mass relays it's all
good they even have your little plaque
on a wall it's really sad everyone's
crying so does it give you what you want
it really depends on who you are like I
said I didn't get everything I wanted
but I definitely got enough when I was
done playing this game I was like you
I am open to playing Mass Effect 3 again
I hadn't played Mass Effect 3 since I
beat it I was like why would I play it
again why so I can you have characters I
love and really sweet cinematics that
almost bring you to tears only to have
an ending that just tells you huh now
I'm not going to do that but now I will
play it again and for nothing else I do
feel that this DLC negates the
indoctrination theory and for those of
you who don't know what that is it's the
theory that the ending of Mass Effect 3
doesn't actually happen is just Shepards
just unconscious and he's being
indoctrinated by the Reapers and it's
all just a big dream and I've seen all
the indoctrination videos no need to
send him to me I've seen them all and
they're very good they're very well put
together well-thought-out videos I just
don't feel it's enough for me to go oh
yeah its indoctrination it's kind of
like that chick is like if you're
smoking how do I know you're not
cheating on me I don't make leaps like
that yeah I just not me when I hear
horse hooves
I think horses not zebras for me if the
Bioware crew went out of their way to
expand on an ending I believe that
ending is probably a real ending it's
what happens I don't know why they would
expand on a dream that turns out to be
[ __ ] plus is the fact that Buzz
Aldrin and that little kid are on that
planet and they're all talking like oh
is that what happened with Shepherd well
apparently not because it was all a
dream now they're probably talking about
it because it happened it's real and
besides when the voice-over is going you
see everyone out in the galaxy and Rex
with this kid and everyone's rebuilding
that indoctrination also it still
doesn't make sense
to have closure for everything and have
it just be [ __ ] have it be a dream
so I think is real not everyone will
agree with me but that's fine because
that's probably what Bioware wants is
why the like no comment on the
indoctrination thing because as long as
there's no comment no one will know for
sure and everyone will speculate
everyone will talk and when people are
talking about your game that's never a
bad thing so if I'm going to speak to
the crew of Bioware honestly completely
from me to you thank you for doing this
Mass Effect 3 DLC it couldn't have been
easy you know to hearing all the fans
that have loved you for years completely
[ __ ] on your game because of the ending
I mean that must have been hard to hear
for you guys you guys could have just
been like I know whatever just deal with
it you don't like the ending tough lock
and so many game developers would have
done that it would have been like
whatever deal with it it's our game but
you didn't you took it as constructive
criticism and you worked with us on it I
really do appreciate that thank you for
taking all the rage of ravenous fans out
there as tough love rather than hate and
animosity as apparently you recognized
we wanted a reason to love the game it's
not like we wanted to hate the game I
just for me to you thank you guys at
Biola so the Mass Effect 3 extended
ending
LC did you play it do you like it is it
restore your faith is it enough is it
not enough comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more